welcome back look at these mother's day
roses from rose box they create long
lasting arrangements with specially
preserved roses with zero maintenance
check out their designs at
roseboxnyc.com
let's go to rocky who has you covered if
you want to to take your mom somewhere
special
absolutely thank you so much jc those
roses are beautiful and for a lot of
moms you know the key to their hearts is
a meal they don't have to cook right
especially when it can be enjoyed
luxuriously at the venetian resort so
let's welcome chef eduardo perez of
mateos and to preview the venetian
specials for our special ladies and you
know the venetian is the resort of love
on the strip so how are we celebrating
overall at the venetian for mom we are
going all the way for mom
so we're gonna do a surf and turf here i
have our filet mignon so you're talking
about the specials specifically at
mateo's ed mateos yes this is what we're
offering in mateo's on a sunday for moms
so here we have a little lobster
that is being already uh cooked
now we're gonna top it off so what we
did is we uh cooked the lobster take the
claw out of the shell and put it in the
cavity over here okay and then we're
gonna we're gonna throw it in the oven
and here oh my gosh we're going to the
oven
we have one that we
added already
i wish you could all smell this at home
it is incredible here we go
wow we have our livestream
that is amazing mom would
she would do whatever you want her to do
actually it's okay
on this side we have we've got the turf
we have the turf
so we have a nice chilean neon over here
so what's your secret to to filet mignon
is it is it the seasoning is the way you
cook it how do you
tell us
of course
actually when you're cooking meat you
got to make sure that your meal is at
room temperature before you start
cooking it that way you can ensure that
it's going to cook all the way through
to the temperature that you want okay
uh if it is cold then uh when you cook
it and you want a medium rare your meal
is going to be rare in the inside so we
don't want that that is why you are in
this chef you have to have a very nice
and hot uh sauteing
when you do it okay so you kind of stir
your meat
so here we have our circumstance see
this plate no wow we're gonna take over
here this is what's going to give it the
eggs is that garlic butter no this is a
foie gras butter
so we're going to let the foreign melt
wow now while we finish this off you
know what else can we enjoy on the
matteo's
menu
we offer a lot from salads to pastas to
fish to meat everything is traditional
italian food okay
uh
a lot of people come to mateo's chest
for our pastas
we have a nice pasta bar where uh if you
come you go and see
our people making the pasta actually in
there so it's kind of like a show
you know yeah when we do that
oh got it the finishing touches this
gives you the little extra essence
yellow you know the flavor the smell of
your
uh what are now what are reservations
looking like for mother's day should
people call in now or is it look what's
going on let's uh give us a call right
now because we are really running out of
reservations we're running out of space
okay but we also have uh austria which
is uh part of our uh
team the family restaurants uh which is
at the san marco square also okay uh if
for any reason you're gonna get a
reservation in mateos always give us a
call at uh beretta and now we are also
offering a nice lobster tail andreia
australian laughter tail but let's get
back to this look at it oh my gosh you
guys just the final i'm gonna hold it up
look at that incredible meal mom elaine
i'm
not sending this to you i wish i could
but come visit me and then i and then i
can take you to matteo tracy open it up
to you
smells so good